Je vous défie d'écraser ce refrain et de ne pas
vous énerver le
chronoshock 14 ils ne vous ont pas dit que
votre entreprise est fermée vous avez fermé l'
entreprise tout est informatisé maintenant les
gens ont une profonde méfiance envers les machines
avez-vous vu terminator ou deux ou  trois
ou quatre vous étiez d'excellents vendeurs mais avouez
que vous êtes des dinosaures
très bien aussi oh
super bienvenue sur Google 5% d'entre vous se
verront offrir un poste à temps plein
les 95% restants d'entre vous nous ne sommes pas en train de
regarder une sorte de jeux de la faim mentale
contre un groupe d'enfants géniaux pour juste
comme  une poignée d'emplois
Wow l'un des chefs d'équipe m'a trouvé Oh
normalement, il suffit de sortir le poing
sans les mots, c'est tout ce qui est nécessaire,
allez mon poing, je me lève là-dedans ouais
c'est définitivement pas bien tes stagiaires
oui ouais zéro avec s'il est si vieux  Je
pensais que tu  étaient importants parfois les
longs plans rapportent le plus gros votre
premier défi créez une idée lorsque les
gens prennent des photos tout le temps alors
que se passe-t-il si vous prenez cette photo et que vous la
mettez en ligne en ligne et que vous la
partagez avec votre front depuis Instagram
mais le mien est plus un partage social sur
la ligne interjection rapide quand vous dites
sur la ligne vous voulez dire en ligne oui
nous avons des règles le panneau rouge indique pas de
panneau vert oui prendre une bière avec votre
patron vous voulez en prendre une froide avec moi
vous laissez  je sais que je ne vais pas attraper un
rhume
avec vous mais salut votre travail trouvez le mâle l'
un de vous deux maintenant
allez trouver le programmeur il s'appelle
Charles Xavier il est professeur à
Stanford il est en fauteuil roulant l'a compris
Stanford  fauteuil roulant oui Charles Xavier
très drôle professeur Xavier nous savons que
c'est toi tu me trouveras à l'extérieur de la
rangée de clubs nous sommes tous ici maintenant je veux partager une
partie de ma sagesse avec vous si c'est
votre Xavier zat totalisé